Eric Boss here with another new
rockstars hot take for The Last of Us
episode 7. do the jokes from the no pun
intended book foreshadow the events to
come on this series possible spoilers
for episode 8 by the way in episode 7
Riley in Ellie read what does the
cannibal do when he's frustrated he
throws up his hands but this is tipping
the hat to the nibble we are going to
meet in episode 8
dead joke what do you call an alligator
who wears a vest the answer being an
investigator which is what Ellie is
doing in this moment to find the pipe
bombs and let's not forget the joke at
the end of episode four did you know
diarrhea is hereditary it runs in your
jeans and Ellie does have an
evolutionary you might say advantage
against the cordyceps fungus something
that would by definition run in her
jeans think about it and I'm holding
toothbrush to think quip for sponsoring
this short click the link in the
description for more details bye